when you play d1 football you are are
you
is it possible for you to get drafted do
you know you're gonna be talking about
me yeah
do I have a draft party Brian do you ask
to have a draft party with my best
friend Joe Glavin son he got drafted you
guys I waited around is that way because
I can watch the draft for I don't know
five to six or your whole life is on
four right every draft is that what
you're referring to
oh my god people don't realize the kind
of [ __ ] it's okay to fail explain this
so you notes you played football for 14
years
yep and this is your dream to play in
the NFL
mm-hmm and there's no question I talked
to guys who played in the NFL said you
were good enough to play for sure I've
got from Denver was yep yeah and they've
said you were good enough to play no
question right sources so so so you
thought I was gonna go you did it had a
great pro day grow yeah number of scouts
thought he went to the combine we went
to protein not the actual combine okay
so what was the job they combine where
they invite I forget how many players
like 75 or the top top okay I forget how
many they invite that's where those boys
are most of them again drop that's the
cream of the crop and then they have Pro
Day where some late round draft picks
and like some free agents will get
picked up there okay pride I tore it up
in the product one of the best pro days
I mean Toyota Toyota just you did
everything that was asked if did my job
you did your job answer okay so now and
as a tight end
okay so now so so go from there
so then I was like man it looks like you
have a pretty good shot because these
agents are telling me like you know the
Buffalo Bills and the Raiders and I
should be a writer you know so we
thought so then draft day I thought
there's a chance you know and then you
ran you win your football weight 260 Oh
your big kid okay 60 and then so
track-day
ran a four six eight not bad fast fast
so so draft a yeah your son at four is
faster than especially me he's so fast
so if my son when my son is eight goes
you're really fast I think my son was
trying to keep I mean what star you say
just Jeanette and Tigers I'm the fast
boy in the world it's genetics he just
starts saying that I've know we're going
the fastest I want to get back to this
but very quickly did you did you did you
give Frank Grillo a [ __ ] because I'll
tell you what he said last night about
what like
I don't know where he goes he goes he
goes I love that guy I love for because
I love him deep love any good pointed
his chest he goes like I get that dude
like he's he's I just loved me in Frank
connect and he went on I'm like I'm like
I love did you guys do I love Frank you
guys connect I'd always defend friends
yeah you guys connected it was it was
hilarious I was like the [ __ ] did I miss
[ __ ] did I miss here now here's the
bummer
franksen replays y'all I knew him I
didn't knew it
it was like he was literally like I was
like dude how long you gonna go on about
[ __ ] Brennan you know I love he's
like I get it I get you guys you guys
are like hid some some I don't know what
the [ __ ] we were we were like a simpie
ah anyway ba ba ba I wish I could drink
with you guys man at night [ __ ] it'd be
the best you should come down should
come down should come down and and have
a meal we order out from a place like
the amount of tourists OPA yeah and you
should come and sit and just have a
[ __ ] conversation no it's really cool
and he's got a great pad does he's got a
great [ __ ] place
now forget all that tell other Geoff so
go back to the dress now you're waiting
and you're waiting to hear you are you
where are you uh the draught part is
that Joe Clough in Stein's house you had
a drap party and Joe we know will Joe
Joe James Joe's draft party but we
thought maybe this but he was picked in
the first you get a call on your cell
phones how I work so you're waiting on
your phone I can wrote every one-f
service here was full bars went yeah me
too all right own air [ __ ] right
never brain well it never rang it never
ring and then probably a week week and a
half the yo or probably two weeks later
there you go hey the bills they give you
shot fly up there but we have to do is
you know they're bringing like six guys
so that you know fly up there and my
dad's like Buffalo Bills I said Papa I
know how this works man this is such a
they're bringing me in as a body because
somebody got hurt some like that it's so
far-fetched I'm gonna make the team
don't get your hopes up he's like yeah
no doubt dad buy his Buffalo Bill
jerseys there's a Buffalo Bill flag
outside the house that's a great guy
drops me off at the airport he's like
you're doing it man I was like and I
knew I was like did I know I'm like I
yeah I'm doing it man
oh man I need I get them just breaks
your heart breaks your heart
Oh whole life oh and then especially
when you are you're as good as those
guys well yeah well but then right
swallow a pill the life stop see that
shit's not gonna happen for you so then
I want to support my best friend Joe
this first game him starting in the NFL
at tight end as a rookie for the st.
Louis Rams I fly out there he gets us
you know we're sitting with his family
and they they announced his name and I
started crying crying bawling crying cuz
I didn't make it I was happy for him I
also feel like I've been that was I've
now I'm talking nots roaring in
uncontrollably not wrong sighs they
played the Minnesota Vikings well well
it's only your whole life and then not
only our home water guys doll doll smile
my brilliance yeah must be tough you
know he's just not what are you gonna do
what are you gonna [ __ ] do we're girls
would hug each other and cry dudes I
don't know what to do that's you know
I'm not a bro I'm like yeah I might rub
dirt on it but it's your whole [ __ ]
life yeah well back then when you're
younger for sure I mean tough girl do
you want to hear something like this is
gonna sound this is nothing compared to
it but I I understand what it's like to
really want something obviously my
career and all that but when I was a
wrestler in high school my senior year I
went to the all to the New England's and
I'm supposed to win the New England's
it's my division supposed to win I lost
by a point to a kid who ended up going
on the win I shouldn't have lost so I
have to go into it so now I get a bronze
medal because I go into he's gonna you
know yeah and I don't think I've ever
cried that hard to this day high school
though I understand I'm just saying I
tried high school I'm just saying that
for me for me at the time and a teen
wrestling was everything and it was it
was everything to me I was the only the
first time I felt like I had sports
victory of that kind right and I was
supposed to win set up so I can't
imagine I can't imagine then you go
another four years where it's your
career and then it just doesn't have but
the I mean you think I'm an athlete but
then you see these graphics like there's
this kid it might have been Tampa Bay
draft him for Tom Brady Elsie to protect
Tom Brady he played he was a center or
tackle at Iowa they showed this kid he's
six eight 360 pounds he ran a four eight
in the 40s some [ __ ] like this at Stowe
and he oh he wrestled undefeated state
champ white he snatched 450 pounds four
times it's a record in Iowa what is this
guy I forget I'm just looking up tallest
and I fell player oh definitely don't do
that Richard she's not giving now I'm
just curious
Oh another King him up yeah if you go to
Iowa draft pick to 2020 Iowa draft pick
you I think he was a sinner but they
shouldn't they show their credentials or
they'll get Simmons the kid from Clemson
got drafted before he even played it
down of varsity football he had a
scholarship offer from Clemson as a
sophomore and he didn't play his
sophomore year cuz he want to focus on
basketball what the [ __ ] man just in
worse 13th pick I think that's him just
a [ __ ] freak man and then some of
these guys you watch them run you like
yeah that's it yeah his daddy died when
he was eight in a car wreck oh yeah sad
man this gets just a freak then they
showed the highlight but he like Jesus
Christ yeah I mean that's just like get
that kid from Clemson ran like oh he ran
he used to long 5 320 pounds mm-hmm
Jesus Christ he ran a four eight
wouldn't refrigerator Perry I remember
when he was 300 pounds nobody could
believe how big we call the refrigerator
yeah he would now hit today I know but
that Simmons kid for Clemson he ran off
for three
he's 240 pounds were in a 4-3 he's
played cornerback linebacker safety and
they go hey you're kind of a tweener so
do you know like when I fell you know
what positioning in a play
he likes camera goes defense defense I
played defense like Jesus Christ just a
staad man I mean I know there's one kid
were swollen oh yeah I'm the [ __ ]
gremlin compared to them but then they
days another kid who's bolt his mom and
dad both ran track
oh what's that both Olympians
so of course he's one if there's any
genetic say I wonder if he's got some
fast twitch muscle then that's amazing
what's amazing to me too is because you
know user drafts a big deal on your in
you it's usually in New York of Chicago
and the whole crowd and fans go nuts but
now it's face time so just them their
family
Joe Barrett Joe Burrell who got draft
number one he's just like what he's a
quarterback quarterback is the best
scorer had the best season of all time
I've not got a long history really well
he's a fascinating guy here what else is
well get off the drafts nuts after this
but never been more excited for a draft
have nothing to do and I watched it on
14 draft the other night yell seven
rounds here's the thing though Joe
burrow here's what's answering Joe pearl
chase young Jeff o dukkha see those
three guys yeah you know they're all in
the same team they all went to Ohio
State
Wow Jeff burrow originally went to Ohio
State was third string was like [ __ ]
this transferred he transferred the LSU
had a decent season the first one in the
second season where do you know he's
gonna want pick best season of all-time
by a by a quarterback he's just sitting
out he figured something out something
clicked you know what's interesting when
you leave an ohio state his all his
family plate alls family played at
Nebraska his dad is uncle they asked
Nebraska Scott frost did he [ __ ] up
the oh hey Joe Burroughs is leaving Ohio
State Joe burrow he wants to go to
Nebraska's family with their do you want
him and Scott frost man I don't think
he's that good Joe Bruin cool I'm gonna
go else shoots him win the Heisman
Trophy that's him
I heard show that's in crap you know
dude you the first pick of the dammit
he's thinking though now I got a produce
there's a lot of pressure
oh yeah pressure yeah beard greatest
season well done and that's what he's
made for he's so goddamn good and then
he was Roger Goodell makes forty million
dollars a year
I understand kisses didn't word my
wooden II his league mates how much
money but what is the president he's the
president is the president wise to get
away you know Weiss Bill Gates make some
okay you know make some hard decisions
oh I got people hate them they hate him
because of the CTE stuff well they did
that right there just you know I mean
look don't watch this one appreciate
that gosh ready to go decided about it
he pretty ready to go coach number one
bake very cool anyway I got stuff to do
what's crazy about him is before the
national champ ship they're doing the
I'm sorry they beat I forget they beat I
think they destroyed Oklahoma right to
get the last championship and that he's
right on the tunnel and they get it in a
really good real quick so you're playing
Clemson the finals you know and you know
how do you think you're doing is oh
we've already won yeah that guy so he's
hockey's [ __ ] well he's cocky but we've
already won he's such a he's such a
beast and how about when he got to LSU
they asked him out football you as I am
football I [ __ ] I am for you need to
have that kind of confidence I think
that people hate it but like dude first
I being [ __ ] a quarterback before
you say that try being a quarterback
with all that pressure Oh who's our boy
we had on remember he came on hilarious
comedian plays mainly black crabs but
white guy Jerry Owen Jerry on goes guys
that's a great tweet he was god damnit
only four white guys were drafting the
first round we got to step it up guys my
guys only and they're all quarterbacks
probably not the only one was a
quarterback the rest we're all I mean
but black guys are not faster than white
guys sitting you know it's are
interesting but how interesting is it
that the top three picks all played on
the sing do you know you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]